qui permette aux étudiants de choisir
et de faire des choix informés.
Quand vous achetez une voiture,
on vous indique la consommation attendue.
Qui sait à quoi s'attendre
d'un diplôme en études canadiennes.
Ça existe réellement, d'ailleurs.
Et s'il y avait une application pour ça ?
Qui mettrait en relation le coût d'une université avec le salaire attendu.
Appelons-la Frais Basés sur les Revenus ou FBR.
Que l'un d'entre vous le fasse.
(Rires)
Découvrez votre réalité.
Il y a trois avantages,
trois bénéfices aux frais basés sur les revenus.
N'importe quel utilisateur peut savoir
combien il ou elle va gagner après l'université.
De tels utilisateurs informés
sont peu enclins à être victimes du stratagème du marchand d'illusions,
du discours de vente.
Mais également de faire le bon choix.
Pourquoi quiconque paierait plus pour l'université
que, disons 15 % du salaire supplémentaire qu'il gagne ?
Il y a un second avantage aux frais basés sur les revenus.
En liant le coût aux revenus,
les administrateurs des universités seraient forcés de mieux gérer les coûts,
de travailler de manière innovante.
Par exemple,
tous vos étudiants payent environ les mêmes frais
pour chaque spécialité.
Ce qui, manifestement, est injuste et devrait changer.
Un élève ingénieur utilise plus de ressources
et de services, de laboratoires et d'espace
qu'un étudiant en philosophie.
Mais l'étudiant en philosophie, par conséquent,
subventionne l'élève ingénieur.
Qui par la suite, dans tous les cas, gagnera plus d'argent.
Pourquoi deux personnes devraient payer le même produit,
payer la même somme,
mais l'une reçoit la moitié ou le tiers du service.
En fait, les diplômés issus de certaines spécialités
payent 25% de leur salaire pour rembourser leur dette étudiante,
alors que d'autres payent 5%.
Ce type d'inégalité devrait s'arrêter
lorsque les prix des spécialités seront mieux évalués.
Bien sûr, toutes ces données --
et l'un d'entre vous va le faire, pas vrai ?
Toutes ces données doivent être bien conçues
peut-être auditées par des firmes comptables
pour éviter les mensonges statistiques.
On connaît les statistiques, n'est-ce pas ?
Quoi qu'il en soit,
le troisième et majeur avantage des frais basés sur les revenus
est qu'ils devraient libérer les Américains
de la peur et la réalité de la ruine financière
suite à l'achat d'un produit défectueux.
Peut-être, dans quelque temps,
les jeunes et vieux Américains pourront redécouvrir,
comme le monsieur le disait plus tôt,
leur curiosité, leur amour d'apprendre --
étudier ce qu'ils aiment,
aimer ce qu'ils étudient,
suivre leur passion...
être stimulés par leur intelligence,
suivre la trajectoire qu'ils veulent vraiment.
Après tout, c'étaient Eric et Kevin,
deux ans plus tôt,
exactement ce type de jeunes hommes,
qui m'ont entraîné et travaillé avec moi,
et qui continuent de le faire,
sur cette étude sur les étudiants endettés aux États-Unis.
Merci de votre attention.
(Applaudissements)